so we have 14x plus 4
over negative 3x minus 2
is equal to 8 and i'll give you a few
moments to see if you can tackle it on
your own
so this equation right here at first it
doesn't look like a straightforward
linear equation we have one expression
on top of another expression but as
we'll see we can simplify this to turn
it into a linear equation so the first
thing that i want to do is i don't like
this negative 3x plus 2 sitting here in
a denominator it makes me stressed
so i want to multiply both sides of this
equation times negative 3x
minus 2
times negative three x minus two what
does that do for us well on the left
hand side you have this negative three x
minus two is going to be over negative
three x minus two they
will cancel out they will cancel out and
so you're left with on the left hand
side
your 14x plus 4 and on your right hand
side you just have to multiply 8 times
negative 3x minus 2. so you are left
with
well 8 times negative 3x is negative
24x
and then 8 times negative 2 is negative
16. and there you have it we have
simplified this to just a traditional
linear equation we've got variables on
both sides so we can just keep
simplifying
so the first thing i want to do let's
say we want to put all of our x terms on
the left hand side so i want to get rid
i want to get rid of this negative 24x
right over here so the best way to do
that i'm going to add 24x to the right
hand side i can't just do it to the
right hand side i have to also do it to
the left hand side and so i am left with
on the left hand side 14x plus 24x
is 38x and then i have the plus 4
is equal to
well negative 24x plus 24x those cancel
each other out and we are left with just
the negative 16. negative 16.
now we just have to get rid of this 4
here well let's subtract that 4 from
both sides
and we are left with and this is the
home stretch now we are left with 38x
38x is equal to negative 16 minus 4 is
negative 20
and so we can divide both sides of this
equation by 38
by 38 and we are left with
x is equal to negative 20 over 38 which
can be simplified further both the
numerator and the denominator is
divisible by 2. so let's divide the
numerator and denominator by 2 and we
get negative 10 over
19. x is equal to negative 10
over 19. and we are done and i encourage
you just to validate this for yourself
it's a little bit of a hairy number
right over here but to take this number
substitute it back into our original
equation and validate that it actually
does satisfy that equation